the world is sick for a surprisingly
modest sounding reason we don't
understand love and yet we're rather
convinced that we do we talk a lot of
love of course but generally in terms of
a dizzying rapture lasting a few months
focused on someone's beauty intelligence
and strength we have high ideals and
refer with confidence to concepts like
justice equality and rights and yet
somehow in the mix we avoid talking of
the sort of love that would give true
life to any of these we are law-abiding
and righteous but we are in the grandest
sense in the public square without love
the most convincing definitions of love
in the West have come from Jesus of
Nazareth which has proved unfortunate
given how easy it is for rational types
to confuse an overcoming of supernatural
faith with a neglect of the subject of
love
to move forward we require a new
philosophy of love in effect a powerful
secular religion of love this should be
read out after the news and its tenets
taught to CEOs and supply chain managers
we should put it on t-shirts and it
should be as common and more useful to
say I'm trying to learn to love as to
announce a desire to become fit or
famous it's no insult to have to
acknowledge that even though we inhabit
a culture soaked in romanticism we have
problems understanding love and even
though we've had plenty of crushes and
heard plenty of songs about love was
still taking our first steps towards
grasping what love might actually be
here then a seven key constituent
ingredients of love charity love means
above anything else benevolence and
gentleness towards what is failed
disgraced broken unappealing angry and
foul in other people and in ourselves
love isn't about an admiration for
strength
it's about directing sympathy in a most
unexpected directions
but what is messed up lost and in pieces
and at what we might hate resent and be
frightened of anyone can express an
interest in perfection to love is to
devote an active charity towards the
mistakes and aberrations one day we will
all require the charity of others in one
way or another we'll be on our knees and
we will need people to look past our
evident failings in a tender search for
our deeply hidden merits imagination to
love with imagination is to look beneath
the surface where there may be rage
cynicism brittleness or transgression
and to picture the suffering and pain
that got a person to this place to love
with imagination is to fill in the
better reasons why others are behaving
as they are imaginative love knows that
we are all somewhere desperate it seeks
out in our desperation and treats it
with sorrowful gentleness kindness there
are so many fighters for social justice
so many people determined to make a
better world they denounce their enemies
and feel certain of their cause but
along the way they have a faithful habit
of forgetting to be kind in their
denunciations of the evils of others
there is precious little mercy humility
tenderness or grace it's not enough to
be right or just to be kind is to know
that everyone even sinners and in a way
especially sinners deserve ongoing
sympathy and mercy it's never simply
because someone is wrong that we have
any right to cease showing them the
greatest kindness forgiveness to forgive
is to know that we are in our own way as
guilty as the next person
given what we all are we have no option
but to cut each other some slack
of course we failed and been hasty and
less than admirable but that's no reason
forever to withhold love we learn to
forgive when we are no longer self
righteous that is when we're brave
enough to fathom the darker sections of
our own hearts
loyalty to love means being loyal to
people this could be ourselves even
though the crowd no longer agrees
outside the mob may be cheering but we
continue on the same side with
steadfastness and an unbuttoned faith
generosity love overflows it isn't about
loving just one person it encompasses
the love of someone you've just met of
strangers in another land of the earth
of plants weevils house bats and that
moth by the window who might be dead by
nightfall patience we want others to
meet our hopes right now but true love
means giving people the time to mature
and develop to go wrong to wander in
another direction and not to shout at
them but to give them every chance to
grow at their own pace towards their
better selves if we can believe
wholeheartedly in some of the above it
won't matter who we vote for or what our
causes we can count as part of what is
helping we should be almost done with
romantic love by now we should be
setting our sights on the challenge of
this sort of love yet it's not
surprising if we're still only at the
beginning we're just starting on the
path to being human
love is a skill that we can learn our
relationships book calmly guides us with
calm and charm through the key issues of
relationships to ensure that success in
love need not be a matter of good luck
for more click the link now